[Rires]
[Musique]
bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre sur
TVfil 78 pour une nouvelle édition du 78
lactu le journal de la rédaction j- 6
avant le premier tour du scrutin des
municipales nous en parlerons dans
quelques instants avec cette question la
parité est-elle enfin respectée cette
année pour l'instant vous allz découvrir
les images d'une partie des salariés de
l'entreprise Diebold France aguille en
cours les techniciens de cette
entreprise en charge de dépanner les
distributeurs automatiques de billets
sont en grève depuis une semaine à
travers le territoire national ils
évoquent des conditions de travail
difficiles la CFDT qui pointe dans le
détail une diminution des effectifs
depuis un an des sanctions trop fortes
également des licenciements les
grévistes et qui récalame l'ouverture de
négociation avec la direction on
manifeste parce que ça fait presque un
an maintenant en avril 2013 que la
direction a décidé de négocier revoir
les aménagements du temps de travail
donc on demandant à ce que les
techniciens travaillent non plus sur une
base de 9 jours par quinzaine mais sur
10 jours donc perdre 24 jours de repos
et actuellement nos temps de trajet sont
considérés comme du temps de travail
effectif de là ils ont décidé de de
supprimer les les repos donc donc 24
jours c'est en en temps homme ben ça
fait se emplois ils ont décidé de de
supprimer les temps de trajet ce qui va
leur permettre de faire travailler les
gens jusqu'à 13h par jour dans
l'actualité de ce 17 mars également le
Solar Decathlon qui dévoile le nom de
son Parin la compétition au cours de
laquelle de jeunes ingénieurs et
architectes du monde entier conçoivent
l'habitat de demain et qui se déroulera
cette année en France à Versailles a
choisi Michel des joyaux pour assurer sa
promotion le navigateur a été séduit par
cette compétition bienenale qui verra
s'affronter 20 équipes représentant 16
pays leur défi réaliser une maison
solaire entièrement autonome en énergie
Michel de joyot le double vainqueur du
vent des globes 2001 200009 il est aussi
l'un des navigateurs en solitaire les
plus titrés au monde rappelons enfin que
le Solar d'cathlon se déroulera du 18
juin au 14 juillet dans les jardins du
château à Versailles donc on écoute
Michel desjoyau micro d'Olivier Manis
calco de Jonathan villman nous parlerit
de son engagement déjà très fort pour la
protection de la planète moi j'ai tout
de suite embrayé sur la proposition euh
à titre perso tout simplement parce que
moi je suis passionné de technologie
d'innovation de compétition aussi euh
mais je suis aussi tout simplement
citoyens mes deux dernières maisons sont
sont équipées de panneaux solaires
thermiques euh même en Bretagne il a
assez de soleil pour chauffer de l'eau
euh et sur la prochaine dont j'ai déposé
le permis de construire récemment euh
j'ai bien l'intention de mettre du
solaire thermique du solaire
photovoltaïque euh de de l'éolien de la
récupération d'autres pluies tout un tas
de de solutions somtoutes qui ne sont
que du bon sens l'invité de ce journal à
présent CEN ayard bonsoir euh vous êtes
coordinatrice des études françaises à
l'Institut d'études culturelles
internationales de l'Université de
Versailles 50 ans en yvelin vous
organisez une semaine dédié à la
Francophonie jusqu'au 21 mars une
semaine qui fait bien sûr écho à cette
journée internationale de la
Francophonie le 20 mars on va regarder
le programme dans un instant mais tout
d'abord on peut peut-être rappeler vos
missions les missions de l'Institut
d'études culturells et internationales
oui donc euh l'Institut d'études
culturells et international est une
composante de l'Université de de
Versailles euh on a des formations
plutôt dans le domaine de l'histoire des
études internationales des langues euh
et particulièrement donc pour ma part en
français langue étrangère au programme
de cette semaine de la francophonie
concours photos exposition aussi on va
voir euh quelques images d'une
exposition qui a d'ailleurs déjà débuté
des conférences des projections tout
cela se fait dans le cadre de
partenariat avec la maison de la poésie
ou encore la maison des enfants elle en
cours vous vouliez cette implication
dans le territoire oui tout à fait euh
c'est vrai que en fait ce qu'on aimerait
c'est que l'université accueille le
public extérieur pas seulement le public
universitaire enseignant étudiants
personnel mais euh mais s'ouvrir puisque
c'est un lieu de rencontre qui est
ouvert à tous on a parfois un peu peur
de rentrer euh à l'univers unité donc
c'est pour ça qu'on a fait appel au
Centre social municipal d'élancour et
entre autres à la maison des enfants et
une association aussi qui s'appelle
alpha plus qui donne des cours
d'alphabétisation et de français langue
étrangère pour les primos arrivants donc
le public extérieur est le bienvenu à
l'université à guyoncour sur le site de
Guy encour l'objectif c'est de faire
quelque chose aussi d'interactif il y a
des quiz il y a des minimétrages aussi
qui ont été réalisés par les étudiants
internationaux voilà le but
effectivement enfin on profite de cette
semaine pour montrer ce que font les
étudiants étrangers à l'université de
versaill Saint-Quentin euh entre autres
dans nos diplômes universitaires on a un
cours qui s'appelle le projet de groupe
où nos étudiants réalisent différents
projet donc là ce c'était des
minimétrages sur leur perception de la
France mais ça peut prendre d'autres
formes comme par exemple un rally
touristique qu'ils ont créé à 5 an en
yeline un blog enfin voilà donc on
essaie de faire la promotion de de ce
qu'il réalise pendant pendant les
semestres mais ces étudiants étrangers
justement qui viennent en France qui
s'intéressent à la langue française à la
Francophonie nombreux la langue
française séduit aussi les étudiants
dans leur parcours oui oui oui oui y a
la langue française séduit en règle
générale euh alors ensuite au niveau du
public on a beaucoup beaucoup
d'étudiants venant d'Asie
particulièrement de Chine mais aussi
d'Amérique latine B bien sûr d'Europe
via les les programmes d'échange
Erasmus donc qui viennent aussi bien
alors pour différentes raisons pour
parce qu'ils aiment la langue française
mais aussi pour la qualité de
l'enseignement en France il y
rendez-vous Iness Iness aussi qui est
peut-être amusant en marge de tout ça
c'est des cours d'argot c'est proposé
par l'association dédié aux étudiants
internationaux c'est pour apprendre aux
étrangers l'Argo en français voà
exactement en fait c'est une association
qui est dédiée aux étudiants
internationaux qui s'est rendu compte
que justement ils avaient quelques
problèmes de communication entre entre
étudiants puisque quand on apprend le
français en règle générale on apprend le
français bah courant
traditionnel et bah quand ils arrivent
là et qu'ils essayent de communiquer
avec des étudiants français il y a
beaucoup beaucoup d'
de de problèmes de compréhension donc
ils ont décidé enfin ils ont eu cette
idée et donc on l'a intégré dans la
semaine de la francophonie puisque ça
fait par enfin c'est c'est vraiment ça
prend c'est à part entière voilà aussi
l'argot le verl pour é les àaise dans
leurs études ça aussi c'est important
voilà tout à fait tout à fait 220
millions de francophones dans le monde
le français langue officiel dans 32
états c'est ce qui vous a poussé un
petit peu à faire cette semaine complète
de la Francophonie alors en fait oui au
départ on était parti sur une journée
mais effectivement vu que la
francophonie c'est c'est tellement enfin
c'est un concept qui qui intègre
énormément de d'idées donc sur une
journée c'était pas possible donc on a
décidé de le faire sur la semaine
complète et c'est aussi pour faire écho
à la Semaine de la langue française qui
est organisé par le ministère de la
Culture et de la Communication euh donc
donc voilà donc des des débats des
rencontres des des conférences et on
espère que ce sera donc c'est la
première édition à l'université de
versaill euh donc on espère pouvoir la
renouveler et justement pouvoir
agrémenter cette semaine d' encore plein
d'autres manifestations c'est de
péréniser vraiment cette manifestation
d' faire un rendez-vous important pour
pour l'anné ou c'est aussi un
rendez-vous on espère que les étudiants
étrangers et les étudiants français
puissent
justement échanger parce que c'est une
grosse demande de nos étudiants
étrangers qui ça veut dire que c'est
difficile les étudiants français ont
tendance à rester entre eux et avir du
mal oui voilà c'est c'est une grosse
demande qu'on a au niveau de de la
population internationale de
l'université ils aimeraient bien
échanger un peu plus et donc on essaie
de mettre en place des actions pour que
ça se fasse tant qu'à venir en France
autant être au contact de français c'est
tout de même effectivement mieux
lorsqu'on vient faire un échange de ce
type là il y a aussi une question qui
seose actuellement c'est l'utilisation
de l'anglais pour les cours à
l'université il y a une possibilité
d'enseigner les cours en anglais ça
c'est la suite de cette loi sur
l'enseignement supérieur en 2013
certains cours peuvent bénéficier de
cette dérogation là une dérogation la
loi 91 94 de de Toubon qui obligeait les
cours en français maintenant il y a des
dérogations quel regard vous avez
là-dessus vous qui êtes là pour
promouvoir la francophonie alors
justement oui je suis très attachée
moi-même à la langue française mais il
faut aussi être réaliste dans le monde
actuel bah si on a envie justement
d'avoir des étudiants internationaux qui
viennent étudier dans nos formations en
France il faut absolument qu'on qu'on
développe les cours pas garder
uniquement le français voilà alors je
pense que que voilà on peut faire une
demi-mesure je pense qu'il y a on
pourrait identifier certaines certaines
filières certains domaines qui attire
justement plus les étudiants
internationaux et développer une partie
des cours en anglais mais pas tout parce
que effectivement il faut aussi protéger
notre langue française voilà il y aura
une rencontre débat sur ce thème dans le
cadre de la Semaine de la francophonie
ce sera jeudi 20 mars à 14h rencontre
débat avec l'association l'avenir de la
langue française voilà pour les
précision merci d'être venu sur ce
plateau nous présenter ce rendez-vous le
premier de cette envergure à
l'université de versaill Saint-Quentin
en nieline le programme complet sur le
site internet de l'université l'adresse
qui s'est affichée bien évidemment merci
à vous merci politique pour poursuivre
ce journal je vous le disais tout à
l'heure dimanche nous nous rendrons aux
hurnnes pour les municipales ce soir la
rédaction se penche sur cette question
de la parité dans les ivelines on compte
une quarantaine de femmes maire pour 262
communes la loi sur la parité a été
élargie les femmes restent cependant ant
souvent cantonné au poste de conseillère
municipal plutôt qu'au poste de maire
c'est ce que vous allez voir avec ce
reportage de Claire
Cambier l'égalité hommes-femme en
politique un objectif affiché par le
gouvernement mais loin d'être atteint en
France et dans les ivelines depuis 2013
l'obligation de liste paritaire au
municipale a été élargie à toutes les
communes de plus de 1000 habitants bilan
16000 conseillères municipales
supplémentaire devrait être élu mais le
nombre de femmes Mair risque lui de ne
pas beaucoup évoluer actuellement nous
avons un peu plus de 16 % de de femmes
mèes dans les Yvelines sur les 262
communes donc la situation est meilleure
que au niveau national des données assez
faibles or selon un sondage ifob de
début mars 70 % des Français
souhaiteraient qu'il y ait plus de
femmes mère notamment parce qu'il
pensent qu'elle ferait de la politique
autrement plus honnête et plus à
l'écoute des habitants pour 82 % des
sondés mais c'est vrai qu'être maire et
présidente d'une interco pour les femmes
je pense que c'est bien moi je je
rencontre beaucoup de plaisiroises qui
me disent madame Le Mire on est très
content que ce soit une femme l'écoute
est différente vous êtes plus peut-être
en ouverture c'est évident une femme est
souvent plus maternante entre guillemets
mais ça n'empêche pas que je sois ferme
et bien décidé qu'est-ce qui explique
alors que les femmes soient reléguées au
poste de conseillère municipal plutôt
qu'à celui de maire les candidats
avancent de raisons majeures le manque
de renouvellement des élus mais mais
aussi une certaine forme d'autocensure
on voit que les hommes n'aiment pas trop
laisser leur leur place il y a plus de
suppléent que de que de femmes député
même à certains certains postes même au
sénatorial et cetera en tête de
liste après je pense que les femmes sont
peut-être plus plus longues à prendre
des décisions à àer murir le
renouvellement prendra donc du temps
mais les lois en faveur de la parité et
les jeunes générations devraient faire
évoluer les choses l'association elles
aussi propose quelques outils pour aller
dans ce sens par exemple un guide de
l'élu pour inciter les femmes à
s'engager et expliquer les acquis au
niveau
professionnel un mot de sport pour
conclure en vous rappelant tout d'abord
que chaque lundi à 18h30 vous avez
rendez-vous avec le 78 sport préparé et
présenté par Anthony R qui fait un point
complet chaque semaine sur les derniers
résultats cette semaine il sera aussi
question du 24e rally des Gazel c'était
ce samedi pour le départ dans les
jardins du Trocadero à Paris le seul
rally Raed 100 % féminin uniquement hors
piste composé cette année de 160
équipages et il y a des ivelinoises
Christelle et Sophie vous les voyez
comme les autres compétirices elles
devront parcourir 6 étapes en 8 jours
sans aucune connexion aide avec
l'extérieur elles emportent évidemment
leur nourriture pour toute la durée de
l'épreuve mais aussi de quoi se dépanner
dans le désert et le matériel nécessaire
à la navigation lactu revient demain à
18h toujours en direct sur TVF Catherine
zulato à la présentation excellente
soirée
[Musique]